it is the highest-profile
entertainment slug that exists I'm Don
Mischer
my company is Don Mischer productions
and we have done six live Superbowl
halftime shows you've got a window of
about six and a half minutes between the
time the players walk off the field and
the time you actually begin the halftime
show in 2006 when we did the Rolling
Stones Mick was very focused he wanted
to have a giant stones logo the tongue
and the lips and all up and Pittsburgh
was playing Seattle the first half ended
something happened in the last play and
the coach was really pissed and he
stayed out on the field and argued with
the referees we need to get this
gigantic set on the field and we
couldn't go until a coach and the
referees left as the clock is running
down and ticking down to going on the
air it got very very tense
I was simply screaming get him off the
field get him off the field it took him
two minutes and then we got the go seven
or eight pieces have begun to come onto
the field and one of the guys pushing
those speeches fell down and the piece
behind him and then we had to worry
about that do we have to stop and bring
an ambulance and we realized we weren't
gonna get this set up in time we called
ABC and said we got a problem can you
have your guys Phil it was Al Michaels
and John Madden and we just asked them
to give us an extra 90 seconds and that
actually worked we just barely made it
it's a very exciting way to earn a
living at least for eight other people
look at me and say why the hell are you
doing this